[Music]
- one [ __ ] three - what
[ __ ] [ __ ] everybody welcome
back to [ __ ] off-the-record where we
talk about whatever the hell we do we
are a train now that's how you get the
run julia is back hi when I walked it up
like oh my god that's right the walls
are painted this way it's been so long
don't you been up to
ya know like ever since your departure
yeah right from JK a lot huh I've been
filming a lot in Sakhalin I've been
noticing that you finally started to
post on Instagram yes
you started posting vlogs yes and then
you also have a different job I do I do
this was actually pretty recent and I'm
sorry I'm making the announcement here
for you guys I just kind of wanted to
keep it private for a little bit just
because I wanted to just like marinate
get used to my job and like be like
pretty much settled in but I'm pretty
good in it now like there for about two
months now
nice yeah do you like it I love it I
love it so much can you talk about what
you do hey can you turn down how much I
weigh brother my producer know right
exacting thing over there they do sugar
J cake and me you love it a lot more
people love it just the same
you're back now does that mean they
didn't continue giving you a job this
time no no I'm actually working from
home nice well you've got double jobs
now so technically like didn't I tell
you you could never leave yeah that's
just a month ago you were on payroll and
you're gonna get [ __ ] bait again
so you're still technically working with
us think about being in quarantine as I
was saving a [ __ ] ton of money right now
what do you usually spend it on I'm
spending more money more money
really yeah duh now I have more time to
go on Amazon I'm always on Amazon I got
passages coming every day something on
Amazon doh don't you look at how long
it's gonna take and say [ __ ] this [ __ ]
eh won't take that long
what are your other options we can't go
to stores sure what are you buying
everything everything why like lobbying
like I actually bought was up you know
I'm putting like a workout gym at home
so and I have like the most it would you
like a pokemon gym oh so I'm not I'm not
battling out of the other trainers or
anything good but so I just have like a
basic weight set up and stuff I wanted
to do cables so I was like okay I'm
gonna try making my own cable machine so
I bought some pulleys on Amazon that's
so and some rope so I'm gonna try to
make a cable machine out of the other
stuff what the [ __ ] so well I'll let you
guys know if it work can I Commission
you to build me a [ __ ] bench press
and a squat rack because I need one and
they're charging like triple the price
right now I'll make it three for you for
like 50 bucks oh where did you come up
with 50 bucks because I know how much
the meadow cause the last thing I made
was a weight tree you know the kind of
like that you can load all the different
weights on and as wheel to everything
the meadow alone was like 15 bucks what
are you think of a good amount of weight
- it's like an 18 I mean a 1/8 inch
thick
meadow so it's pretty strong there's a
metal supply place by my house is like
Venice applies places everywhere you
weld it they're going to like Home Depot
or something you know home people like
charges up the ass for metal you don't
you know
there's no bite would there either like
it's super expensive you only go there
if you need to but yeah you know cuz
Home Depot is the only place where you
can go on your phone be like I tell me
where the plumbing section is aha no
they look and they don't know we got
like two different sizes of pipes and
like only like three square tubes you
you can't make anything with that so you
go to the places where it's like in the
backyard of like some like industrial
park yeah yeah yeah yeah that kind of
thing oh my god I did something that was
pretty manly the other day my friend
gave me a punching bag
you know the stand-up one and then it
was missing the screws and I was like
where the screws at homie and he was
like sorry I lost it so I went to Home
Depot and I found the right screws and I
used that and I've made it work the
finding the screw myself instead of
calling somebody and saying hey can you
build this [ __ ] for me I'll pay you this
is pretty great though to find that one
screw you and I've been I've been trying
to install bidets at our house and like
and we I needed to find this one piece
that we were missing and like it took me
like five trips back and forth so like
by one and fitted in a like I'm actually
just taking that part oh yeah that's how
I found the smiler but when I finally
found the right piece so I was like oh
[ __ ] man there was another screw on
them on the punching bag so I unscrewed
that and saw that it fit so I just took
that and I was like yes sir can you help
me find this screw and then they've
sized it for me and then also yeah I
still I still hope but you bother with
doing my body weight while
man yeah so so I was taking shower and
then the water wasn't draining so then I
took off your badly here was clogging it
[Laughter]
I took off that what does it think all
this is the number hairnet
no the the [ __ ] dream yeah I took
that [ __ ] off with the screwdriver yep
two of them and then it got it out and I
took the hair out my man the air yeah be
nice if you have to take off a
screwdriver mine just like flying
everywhere what's flying everywhere look
at your thing yeah mine secured not with
the screw I think you just stuck there
forever so I can't I can't even adjust
it yeah oh oh sure you guys been saving
money though during this time no house
we're like buying everything we're
buying everything to buy everything
though it's gonna be a while we'll see
how long this you know for the future
right now okay I'm trying to make
memories with you guys right now are
things taking longer to get to your
house because of all the craziness yeah
we have like missing furniture like they
were supposed to be delivered like last
week and we have no word of when they're
gonna come they didn't show up the day
they were supposed to come we're trying
trying to call like you know life sounds
like it's spa it's like no one's working
I'm like oh [ __ ] like even Amazon is
delivering slower yeah no more to day
prime so before like we got used to
Amazon they're just delivering normal
online order to ours
yes I got I gotta wait three days no
same-day delivery it's just letting it
quarantine she's letting us know how how
spoiled we really want I think so you
also think that I got used to now but I
get the tutorial be so mad like we need
to posit something it takes literally
instant or like say if you go from venmo
to your bank it's now instant
transaction where I used to take like
three days no no you don't have to pay
for instant it's like 25 cents it's one
percent of your whole deposit isn't up
till eight twenty five cents all right -
only yeah something you always too much
for me I'm waiting throws those three
days yeah
- I'm on the same boat with you yeah
yeah I don't even know what you guys are
talking about yes on venmo
when you deposit money from your mo
count into your big oh they have like
different days of when that money will
be in your account yeah it's like
anytime you transfer between banks you
know it just looks like stuff like that
that you would never expect - especially
now during this time when stuff like
goes back to what it used to be or what
it is for like other people for us we
take for granted like something that's
like even like cellphone like if your
cell phone service goes out like just a
quick text right now something that I'm
like all [ __ ] so I hate using cash
I [ __ ] always hate using cash I love
just charging in [ __ ] because it's just
a faster transaction I would have to get
anything the exchange is quicker but now
like when I have to like buy something
that requires interaction I'm just like
where their hand gonna land and I'm not
even use my card because I don't want
any sort of germs like here to take my
money oh and then if they give me a
receipt I'm like looking at what corner
they're touching it's the [ __ ]
Wildish oh you know what's crazy I'm
like I'm so like I can't bring myself to
tell them hey can you just put on the
floor of the food and put the food
delivery so whenever I - well no not
sure you can choose this lobster if you
choose I haven't selected the option
because so when they reach it over
you're like oh well no I always end up
touching their hands your hands I know
and not have to like [ __ ] wash my
hands every single time I'm like getting
some like food and even before this
that's why I thought when I would fluid
drive through when you have them in your
car tonight I feel a graphic your head
like this yeah they take the card away
yeah I got a burrito the other day and
when I paid for it with my card I got my
card back and it was wet I was like it's
not even it's not even raining right now
why is my hard way and then I went to
get food last night and then it was
weird so like first time this happened
to me instead of them taking my card
they handed me a bucket to throw my like
stuff into last time which is like cool
concept at first right but when you get
the bucket back you're like trying to
get your card and reaching around and
touching every
with a bucket and I was like this is a
terrible plan she'd have tongs or some
[ __ ] oh that would be good it's kind of
like you know that claw machine thing
that you could get for each yeah you
would just start using those things I
use everything with Apple pay now with
like at the grocery store Oh what
happens it's like you you don't touch
anything you don't touch anyone but when
you go and you put your card into the
Machine you stub to type in your PIN or
whatever you still have to do all that
fun well what about when they grab your
things and put it in the bag well that's
fine there at least I think like keeping
somewhat clean but like now this is all
the customers are coming and touching
the same pad because even if you use a
credit card you want to type in a pin
you start to say like no this or this
yes I excited I know how do you feel cuz
you're like super or at least you were
super OCD about like germs and [ __ ] are
you like happy or you're scared now no I
feel like it's I'm used to it now
oh so this is normal you're like finally
someone like this is a burden this is
like oh this is what I feel like we
should be doing you know so it's always
been a pandemic in your head my whole
life is this I feel like we've all been
more self conscious now or like
conscious about just everything like
space germs I like it more because I
don't like touching people or being near
people generally like even when I go to
restaurants I hate it when waiters come
and ask me Abbi I'm like just leave me
alone I'll call you over when I need you
do you like the Korean button thing yeah
yeah no except I don't want to touch the
button you know what do you like yeah
they're pissed off the whole time talk
to you at all did you stay in the corner
and hang out with the grandma and when
you need them they'll come over that's
the best way to do it my people know
you're just used to that kind of service
yeah yeah Asians like in Asian you don't
shake each other's hands and so your
distancing yeah like so they just
announced like whoever the White House
doctor is the one I suppose we're on the
news like Fauci or something that
absolutely won't we shouldn't ever shake
people's hands again yeah again cuz I
don't like shaking hands so that's like
so hard for Americans because Americans
obviously won't even say another what if
we have a cool handshake we worked on a
dare
five patches brand-new ones that all go
with the air it looks so stupid to do
wash our [ __ ] we all been like drinking
a lot more so like Bush we still want to
cheers we still want to go back to our
customs but now we like stay away we do
like that you're still doing so that's
how Bart and I have sex you're just like
[ __ ] me and imports like all right oh
yeah I think even this morning I was
about to hug to you and Casey but then I
was like oh I miss hugging you know
Julia's don't do it don't do it
yeah dude was I gonna say oh my [ __ ]
comment [ __ ] you up because you thought
should I say her [ __ ] so so yeah but
that was it but it threw me off guard
but you know okay so you know how
Europeans went through the same [ __ ]
Spanish flu right and then but they
continued to shake hands and all that
stuff but that's why that's no gettin
[ __ ] now because in Japan like you
know the I think the reason why they
bound all that said the whole touching
thing but the whole math thing I didn't
know that that started from Spanish flu
oh really
yeah cuz you know how in Japan everyone
was already wearing the face masks and
then they're saying that that was some
kind of like it was just because
everyone was doing that during Spanish
flu and then they just continued it so
then if they are sick they keep it in or
they're like they have a low immune
system they just hold so Asians learn
from their mistakes and I have this
interaction though like I I hate people
like I just I I could do without people
okay that sounds extremely we all leave
right now
I just miss it so like if if I were to
go to the like give them money and then
they'd do the whole Matt thing like
thing I'd be like Oh payment I kind of
miss it right now this imagine their
hands are super wet and long crazy and
you're like oh yeah
that's true I pictured a Walmart worker
that's just been greasy all day like
yeah I'm just a positive person all
right I just pictured a hot person you
just said you hate people she hates
people unless they're hot okay yeah yeah
yeah those are the rules so you want a
hot attractive kind good clean smelling
person
to give you a handshake that's it is
that hard is that too much to ask for
and I don't think that's abnormal how
are you doing when you what do you mean
because you're super extroverted like
you're about like people give you energy
sigh I had to check in with you because
I'm like are you okay
that's what I thought cuz I was like I
don't know how I'm gonna even do like a
week by myself I [ __ ] love this [ __ ]
I realized that I don't have the ability
to not be bored and in it's cuz I made
the connection right I was like I'm
already living in my head cuz it's not
that different you just made that
connection no I mean like I don't live
with people in existence you guys are
all figment of my [ __ ] imagination is
is it because you could make friends
with your lemons and you're like all of
my friends are here now I don't need
anybody else yeah I mean like I I don't
feel like I miss anyone because if I
want them they're there my head and my
memory and like yeah and then the sorry
really here Joe if I want you to be I
can block you out nice kitty but but so
so here's the thing right like I thought
I was like I needed this 24/7 in the
comfort of humans in my presence but I I
continuously like continue to interact
like when I got back I was doing phone
conferences and then like after my
quarantine I went immediately out to
like donate masks and all this stuff
right so just that was enough for me
because it was stimulating my mind and
then I just focused my busy to just
doing [ __ ] at my house what about when
you're eating cuz that's like I feel
like when you're just the chilies right
you have to focus on one task and you
can't do karate here
see the way I eat I get up like five
times to set up my food I'm watching a
video or sometimes I might have my
laptop there and I'm chatting while I'm
eating or like I'm taking pictures while
I'm doing I mean like I'm constantly
moving so I feel busier now than I did
before because before you had to behave
and be like I have to be normal and not
move so much and like there was yeah
more sitting but now I'm now you don't
need a [ __ ] butt ass naked cooking
[ __ ] free meals at once yeah I don't
know I'm pretty sad at I don't scratch
my balls while I cook I bet I mean hair
falls out down there I my dick doesn't
go over the counter I'm pretty sure it
was like randomly like I have to [ __ ]
that whew that's true there's always
some random Pew yeah I'm like what that
[ __ ] dude it's like how girls have like
hair everywhere like guys have random
dick hairs everywhere I don't know why
nope no nope well I'm shaved all over it
for you here has someone to interact
with I'm the only one that lives alone
I'm glad you think that
I totally just register that right now
yeah yeah yeah I don't think I could do
it I don't think I could like live alone
even when I had roommates before and
everyone left for a weekend just for a
weekend firm to go home or whatever I
thought I was going crazy really
couldn't do it I love it really I think
I would I would go crazy dude like I
don't even need them to be there and to
interact with me but just knowing we're
in the same space you know what I mean
like even if they stayed in that room or
whatever like even now like I'm in my
garage all the time my girlfriend like
working in our office all the time but
just the fact that we're in the same
space it's I don't know it's at night
when you're not alone yeah yeah yeah
yeah I can't do it maybe I'm not an
extra world like I thought I was or are
you just crazy enough that everyone's
always there like you said so that's
matter I want to know how long I can do
this for after this I think you might
get lost I'm afraid that if you keep
going longer you're not gonna come back
get deeper inside your mind yeah he's
not gonna come back dude I don't know I
love it though like I didn't realize how
much I would love it like more than
going back to regular yes
oh yeah yeah yeah we got to send him
someone you got to live with somebody
dude he's already good descending into
madness dude it's pretty awesome like I
wish I can do this
like when I found out that we're
quarantine until the 30th I was like
values a vacation yes yes dude this is
awesome
I forget the end of this you're gonna be
going into stores with your bag of
lemons and trying trade everybody lemons
instead of money because you're like
this is the new standard guys don't you
understand I got a whole gym set with
two bags of lemons shoutouts to Noah
thank you very much what do you mean oh
you traded you bartered no I just gave
him lemons and he gave me weights he
gave me a punching bag he gave me kick
pads ah
why was he like bro you're looking kind
of weak he doesn't know the word all
right we're going back to the old school
[Music]